hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round one of the American
Cup uh definitely not 1985 it's actually
2023. uh let me just fix that real
quickly there we go uh yeah it's from
the first round of the American Cup
eight very very strong Grand Masters are
playing uh Hikaru here Samuel sevyan uh
Fabiano is playing uh Wesley so he's
playing Dominguez Perez is playing uh
Ray Robson is playing uh so I think I
covered it all yeah
and uh they will play two classical
games and only the two classical games
are drawn they're gonna go into tie
breaks then they're gonna play Rapids
and armageddon's and it's a quite a
beautiful game uh uh definitely a nice
positional squeeze so for those of you
who enjoy that you will really enjoy
this one and also if you want there is a
link in the description below first
thing you will see it's a an interview
with a former world champion Derek as
part of uh regarding the upcoming World
Chase championship match between dingler
and diani punish you work as part of as
it says in the quote above the board
that the match between nepo and ding is
a great show anyway but it's not a World
Chess Championship match because you
can't have a world championship match
without
um the strongest chess player in the
world being actually present in the in
the match says okay it's going to be a
nice one but um you know not really and
he says it's a very different situation
than in 1975 when Fisher decided not to
play chess ever again then okay carp of
uh uh was awarded the world to
championship title but the Fisher never
played chess again Magnus is very active
in his um goals of of playing chess he
even wants to achieve a 2900 rating and
he plays pretty much every tournament he
can get and he plays pretty much every
chance he can get he plays like a 200
bullet games online you know after uh
when he comes home at night so it's a
very different situation okay if you
want to check it out first link in the
description below he also talks about
some other stuff like holidays are going
into fashion and okay so it's some 14
minutes you feel free to check it out
but now let's return to the game in 90
minutes uh is the is the time format
then you get additional time so let's uh
check it out a very nice classical uh
event uh so Hikaru with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to E5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and the bishop to
B5 The Rue Lopez is on the board with a
six morphe's defense Bishop to A4 Knight
to F6 and now Pawn to D3 castles is the
main move here Hikaru already going a
little bit crazy here with the only the
second most popular reply Ponto D3 we
have D6 pontacy for now going for the
duras variation uh stopping B5 and also
keeping around that D5 Square Bishop to
G4 by Samuel and now H3 Samuel trades
here captures captures and now Knight to
D7 the Knight can now be shifted to C5
to put pressure on the bishop Bishop to
E3 covering C5 and now E7 with Knight to
C3 Knight to a f8 and now we have Knight
the E2 there are some games overnight
the D5 was played also B4 is definitely
a move you could consider here as the
Knight is pinned but Hikaru goes nice to
E2 and it is now as of move 11 that we
have a completely new game so okay
Knight T6 the Knight now has access to
D4 and um
uh and therefore and also uh seems to be
stopping D4 but not really this is now
the moment the execute D4 while the C6
Knight is still pinned so D4 by Hikaru e
captures we have Knight captures night
uh Knight captures Bishop captures and
now uh Samuel just castles here uh and
you might think okay now Hikaru has the
bishop pair he's probably gonna Castle
gonna put pressure on the black king
maybe the bishop is coming up to this
diagonal maybe the bishop is coming to
this diagonal uh but no Hikaru actually
plays Bishop captures on C6 and this
will be crucial uh in the uh
continuation of the game sort of has a a
Fisher vibe to it B captures and C6 and
now Rook to D1 as Fisher very often gave
up that that lights were Bishop uh for
the Knight and uh well no one was safe
in that variation not in this particular
variation but there were occasions where
Fisher did it Rook to E8 and now Queen
kingside castles even though Fisher
really loved his light Square bishop and
he often kept it safer for for the
entire game Bishop to F6 offers traded
Bishops and now Hikaru plays C5 uh very
nice positional idea point is that uh it
seems that you can capture because now
if Bishop captures the queen will just
capture but you can also Play Bishop
captress on C5 open up an attack on the
black queen and after the queen moves
you could play Bishop to D4 and now the
problem is let's say Bishop captures The
Rook captures and C5 you can play Rook
to D5 attack the pawn here and if Queen
E6 goes after the E4 Pawn you can just
play Rook the C1 and now if everything
gets traded off let's say captors
captures root capture Sunny for rokule
captron C5 and of course white is much
better here yes material is equal but
these two pawns are incredibly weak you
are going to lose this spawn next and uh
you know it's gonna start off with white
being up a pawn and then it might
eventually be even up two pawns so
instead after C5 we have rooked the C6 a
rook D6 by Samuel now comes Bishop
captures on F6 Queen captures and here
Hikaru trades Queen characters but now
not Rook captures with G captures uh
probably with idea of advancing F5 and
trading 4D
uh E4 Pawn so F3 by Hikaru now Rook the
B8 putting pressure on the B2 Pawn he
covered defensive Rook to F2 now Rook
the B5 goes after the C5 Pawn this is
how Samuel gains activity for his Rooks
Rook the C2 and now the captures on C5
the problem is ifro captures them Hikaru
just traits and you're left with a
triple Pawn here the uh it's very
unlikely that you will be able to to
survive this game so instead after Rook
to C2 with d captures on C5 still a
tripled Pawn uh but now Hikaru gets
rooked to D7 it's a triple Pawn but
there are two Rooks in the game uh or
rather two pairs of Rooks in the game so
it's a bit more Dynamic and now we have
Rook the D6 uh the problem with the move
like Rook to B7 just defending the pawn
is that you can play Rook to d8 checking
to G7 and now shift The Rook over to A8
going after the A6 spawn and it Rook to
B6 then look at those Rooks they're
they're just terrible Rooks uh let's say
uh B3 Rook D5 King two King is coming to
E3 and white is much much better here so
Hikaru really applying a nice positional
squeeze here we have Rook to D6 instead
and now Rook captures on C7 grabbing
back the pawn we have Pawn to C4 now
trying to give up the C4 Pawn for the B2
Pawn but Hikaru just starts bringing the
king into the game we have Rook to B6
and now King to E3 King to G7 and now
Rook to A7 we have rooked the D3 with
check but even King to F4 and even
though uh okay the material is equal but
Hikaru has two Pawn islands and Samuel
has four Pawn Islands uh not only that
he has uh two sets of doubled pawns with
Rook to D4 and now Pawn to H for Hikaru
can now take all the Time in the World
to improve his position as much as
possible because Samuel's Rooks are just
stuck in a very bad place King to G6
Ponte H5 check even this is possible to
to try to gobble up the F7 Pawn King G7
now comes with Rook to A8 we have Ponte
H6 preventing any H6 from Hikaru in the
future and now Pawn to a for preparing
A5 to get the Rook off of the defense of
the A6 Pawn so C5 you need the the sixth
rank to be able to defend the pawn from
there A5 and now Rook the C6 we have
rooked the B8 and this is a beautiful
move by Hikaru now uh the idea is either
you play Rook to B6 you you trade off
the Rooks create a pass Pawn then this
Rook has to go back and uh by that time
this Rook will just gobble up all of the
pawns on the C file or you will bring
the king back trade off this Rook for
this rook and then go for Rook to B6 so
uh there are many many ways to play this
with King page seven Samuel really
without any active plan he just has to
wait and see what happens King to E3 we
have King to G7 now King to E2 with Rook
the E6 now trying to get F5 in but
Hikaru of course stops at Pawn to G4 we
have rooked the C6 and now Rook to D2
trying to trade off this works you can
play this fancy Rook to B6 move Rook the
C7 now and here comes Rook the B6 going
after the pawn so Rook C to D7 now
threatening Rook captures on D2 and okay
Hikaru has the trade now captures
captures and The Rook captures an A6
Hikaru grabs the pawn but okay Samuel
also has now C and the d-pawn and d-pawn
is now a past Pawn but Rook the C7 he is
looking to advance the pawn to C3 now
Rook to D6 by Hikaru attacks the D4 Pawn
we have rooked the B7 Knuckles after the
B2 pawn and Hikaru blocks Rook the V6
Rook back to C7 of course Samuel hoping
for a repetition but not likely Hikaru
advances the pawn to A6 C3 with captures
on C3 and now Rook captures on C3 well
you're probably expecting B capture D
captures on C3 it's not much better
because kingly1 C2 checking C1 there's
no way to advance the pawn and Rook B7
is coming and if we moved Rook then just
Rook a king captures on C2 of off goes
to the pawn
so Rook captures in C3 was played this
still keeps everything in the game also
puts pressure on F3 but now Hikaru just
plays A7 and now of course you cannot
promote you cannot allow Queenie you
have to prevent it by playing Rook to A3
Rook the B7 and now Rook to E3 with
check Hikaru can go uh to D2 you don't
have to worry about the F Pawn because
A8 Queen so Rook goes back Rook to A3
and now Rook the C7 we have Pawn to F5
the problem is uh now uh Samuel is in a
total took swung uh there's nothing he
can do you cannot move the Rook away
from the third rank because you allow
King D3 and King captures you cannot uh
move the king away from the defense of
the F7 Pawn because Rook captures you
cannot play the king to the back rank
because a rook C8 check follows by uh
followed by just promoting a pawn to a
queen you can go here this is covered by
the pawn so the only thing left is F5
it's not much but it's the only move he
has Ponte E5 by Hikaru now preparing E6
the gobble up the F7 Pawn F captures and
G4 with f captures on G4 and it was in
this position animal 52 that Samuel
Savion resigned to the game as there was
nothing more to be done here uh the
problem is for those of you who are
interested
um in how the game might uh have a
finished if it was continued let's say
you throw in a couple of checks because
throwing in checks is basically the only
thing black has car will eventually
gobble up the D4 Pawn let's say Rook the
A4 with the check King to C5 Rook day if
I would check King to B6 now you have to
go back and now just Pawn to E6 this
settles a rook to B1 check you will
throw in a few more checks King to cesa
King to B7 Rook to be one checking to C8
now again you have to stop promotion but
now Pawn to E7 and now this Pawn
promotes so you are you are getting a
queen and then you will Checkmate the
black king but yeah after this F
characters and G4 move uh Samuel had
enough and Hikaru is the only one to win
a game uh in the uh in the in the first
round of the American Cup and he doesn't
Advance right away to the semi-finals
because like I said two classical games
will be played and only if it's a draw
then we go in to wrap it into Armageddon
and so on but now Hikaru only needs a
drawn and he will uh he will be
victorious if you're interested in the
other pairs uh level and Aryan draw
against linear Dominguez Perez Wesley so
drug and Sam Shanklin and Fabiano
caruana drew his game against Ray Robson
so that's it for the uh for the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and yeah if you
guys are interested in the Kasparov
interview first link in the description
below uh so uh yeah I would like to
thank Peter gabertson Matthew Benoit
Andrea avocadlian Frank Ploy and Paul
hinemund for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions but also following up on the
American Cup and how it um you know just
evolves so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend